hola bienvenidos en este vídeo lo que
quiero hacer es tratar de dar otro
ejemplo en el que usemos nociones de
combinatoria para resolver un problema
de probabilidad y lo que me voy a
preguntar es voy a volver a utilizar una
moneda justa una moneda que es
igualmente probable que caiga águila que
caiga sol y me voy a preguntar por todo
por la probabilidad de obtener
exactamente exactamente
mente tres águilas
en 8 volados en 8 volados
eso es lo que voy a querer encontrar
cuál es esa probabilidad y bien antes
que nada quiero que recuerden una de las
primeras definiciones que usamos para
probabilidad que nos decía que la
probabilidad de algo es igual a el
número de casos favorables un número de
resultados favorables de resultados
estados favorables
favorables y que era un resultado
favorable pues era simplemente algo que
satisfacía nuestra condición en este
caso un resultado favorable sería
obtener exactamente tres águilas en ocho
volados y eso lo voy a dividir entre
en número de resultados posibles de
resultados
todos
posibles es decir me echó ocho volados y
cuento cuáles son todas absolutamente
todas las cosas que me pueden pasar ya
sea que tengan tres águilas o no y
recuerden son exactamente tres águilas
no quiero más que tres águilas bien si
me fijo primero en esto en el número de
resultados posibles cuánto es ese número
pues me voy a echar ocho volados así que
en el primer volado me puede salir
águila o me puede salir sol ese es el
primer volado en el segundo volado me
puede salir águila como puede salir sol
igual en el tercero en el cuarto quinto
sexto séptimo y octavo así que tengo
estos ocho volados cada uno tiene dos
posibilidades por lo tanto el número de
resultados posibles es 2 a la 8 si me
fui un poco rápido para ustedes les
recomiendo checar los vídeos que hay en
el tema así que bien el número de
resultados posibles es 2 a la 8 y que
hay del número de resultados favorables
vamos a ver eso ahora ok para encontrar
el número de resultados favorables
quiero que pensemos en lo siguiente
vamos
hacer una pequeña tabla vamos a poner
aquí los volados los voy a enumerar
podría ponerles en realidad cualquier
nombre incluso incluso les podría poner
hubo paco y luis y otros cinco nombres
pero lo más fácil es simplemente
llamarlos bolado uno volado dos volado
tres volado cuatro volado cinco volado
seis y volados siete ahora bien si
quiero exactamente tres águilas en estos
ocho volados entonces esencialmente lo
que voy a hacer si fuera digamos el dios
de la probabilidad es escoger tres de
estos a me faltó 13 de estos 8 volados
de manera que escojo cuáles de ellos van
a ser águilas y todos los demás van a
ser soles por ejemplo podría decir vas a
obtener un águila en el segundo volado y
un águila en el quinto y un águila en el
séptimo y todos los demás van a ser
soles y ese es un evento posible pero
también podría decir vas a obtener
águila en el primero águila en el
segundo y águila en él
cualesquiera de estos dos si todos los
demás fueron soles satisfacen mis
condiciones
así que esencialmente lo que quiero
hacer es de estos ocho volados elegir
exactamente tres y sólo esos tres van a
ser águilas así que si quiero tomar ocho
elementos y escoger tres lo que me dice
eso es que debo considerar el
coeficiente binomial y les recuerdo les
recuerdo la fórmula en general siempre
que vean este símbolo en acá es el
número de combinaciones de n elementos
tomados de canca y la fórmula nos dice
que esto vale n factorial entre k
factorial por n
- k factorial si no saben de dónde sale
esta fórmula y tienen averiguarlo les
recomiendo ver la lista de reproducción
de combinatoria pero bueno en este caso
en este caso de aquí cuánto vale esta
fórmula cuanto vale 8 en 3 pues 8 en 3
es lo mismo que 8 factorial entre 3
factorial por 8 menos 3 factorial
es decir 5 factoriales
y cuánto es esto pues veamos esto es 8
por 7 por 6 por 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por
1 dividido entre
viviendo / voy a dejar este 3 factorial
por aquí ahora y multiplicar por 5
factorial que 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
ahora bien
este caso de aquí 5 x 4 x 3 x 2 x 1
cancela este cachaco los dos son 5 x 4
portales por 2 por 1 así que me queda es
esencialmente esto de aquí
esto de aquí ahora bien que representa
esto de aquí pues si se fijan 8 por 7
por 6 es lo siguiente si yo elijo el
primer lugar donde va a aparecer un
águila entonces tengo 8 lugares entre
los cuales podría elegir y elijo uno ya
ocupe ese lugar y me quedan 7 lugares
entre los cuales puedo elegir
poner la segunda águila y ya que elegí
ese me quedan 6 lugares para poner la
tercera águila y este 3 factorial lo que
está haciendo es evitando que cuente
doble e incluso triple en este caso
porque ya que puse un águila aquí da lo
mismo si es la primera la segunda la
tercera las tres son águilas así que
esta es la función de dividir entre este
3 factorial quitar esas repeticiones de
otro modo sólo tendrían las
permutaciones este 3 factorial quita las
repeticiones
y bien cuánto es esto cuánto es 8 por 7
por 6 pues esto es 8 por 7 por 6 entre 3
factorial que es 3 por 2 por 1 que es un
6 al cancelar esto con esto y obtener
simplemente 8 por 7 que es 56
o lo que es lo mismo esto es 2 al cubo
por 7 ok y ese es el número este es el
número de resultados favorables es el
número de resultados en los que obtengo
exactamente 3 águilas en 8 volados de
modo que la probabilidad vamos a volver
ya a la probabilidad original
la probabilidad
y obtener exactamente tres águilas en
ocho volados
en 8 volados
es de cuánto pues es de el número de
eventos favorables que es 2 al cubo por
7 2 al cubo por 7 dividido entre el
número de resultados posibles que vimos
que era 2 a la 8 entonces entre 2 a la 8
y esto cuanto después es 7 entre 2 a las
5 o lo que es lo mismo 7 entre 32
bien entonces 7 entre 32 cuánto es eso
0.21 87 5 ok entonces este número de
aquí es lo mismo que 0.21 87 5 o si lo
quisieran escribir como un porcentaje
esto es el 21 punto voy a redondear 9
por ciento de los casos dicho de otro
modo la probabilidad de obtener
exactamente tres águilas en ocho colados
es poco mejor que una en cinco pero
bueno lo más importante de este problema
y qué es lo que espero que se lleven con
ustedes es que podemos utilizar métodos
combinatorios para atacar problemas de
probabilidad este mismo método lo
podrían utilizar y de hecho los invito a
hacerlo para resolver problemas como
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener cinco
águilas en 14 bola dos o tres águilas en
siete volados cualquier problema de ese
estilo se puede resolver con este método
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo